[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
as you can see
I don't have dirt here with me today
I've decided to give everyone a break
man I don't know why my camera all of a
sudden I ain't I mean it will like focus
and then it won't focus gotta mess with
the settings again it probably factory
reset again I don't see now it's working
I don't know it's weird what's going on
guys man I didn't even
I'm feeling a little bit better a little
bit better flame like not not entirely
better
but I am feeling a little bit better
like I'm not a hundred percent back
uh
but I'm enough where I could talk for a
little bit
um you know my uh keep in mind this
isn't the standard podcast
uh got stuff going on
but you know I figured we talk about a
little bit of things that I've seen man
talk about a little bit of things I'm
seeing uh for instance I saw the uh
Carla Moriarty comments I know a lot of
people were talking about that you know
we could talk about that a little bit
now talk about anything you guys really
want to talk about probably gotta be
about 45 minutes to an hour
and then I I'm gonna wrap it up for the
day
got a lot of stuff just I just don't
know why it's all it's focusing the way
it is it's never done this before
oh my God it wasn't doing it yesterday
either
I don't know
it's weird
yeah the Todd Howard thing is good I I
saw uh he was giving a lot of props to
Microsoft and you know making one
[Music]
one platform
I have played a little bit of
vampire survivors
can't say that I'm like
the biggest
fan of it like I don't think it's a bad
game but it may not just be for me
uh I don't particularly like it too much
I feel like it's a lot of RNG
am I the only one that feels that way
like there's just an absurd amount of
RPG in that game
that's just me though
what's up nine lives what's going on man
what's going on so as you guys can see
my uh
my sinuses are still a little messed up
I still feel like uh
see I don't I don't know how to do that
and what's funny is
what's funny is like
there's not a lot of like examples I
feel like there should be a place where
you could go
and vampire survivors and it shows you
what every ability is and like how it
works
I just I feel like there's better ways
to make that I get it's an indie game uh
it's fun for a lot of people and I'm not
saying I haven't enjoyed it it's just uh
you know maybe I need to jump in there
and play that a little bit more
Starfield redfall and Motorsports 2023
going to be lit
I'd agree with you
I would definitely agree with you on
that matter
I don't know why
this just randomly switched and turned
off
and then it's not all kinds of technical
issues today man all kinds of technical
issues today
see it will have no problem like it
keeps picking up my background like
that's not how this works camera
what's going on hard hard find hard find
you know I have been playing a game that
I think you guys might enjoy
hold up let me see
let me let me boot it up here
you know I'm probably gonna play this
game while we while we play while we
talk
because uh I think it's easier for me uh
what's up miles
uh what are you playing I'm playing
everything right now I'm on I'm on Steam
that's what I'm currently playing stuff
on Steam
it's just you know it's been a rough
time man it's been a rough time I've had
a very rough week and a half
feeling like death man what's up dirt
we doing pretty good you know miles you
know what I could do is I could show you
what what I'd be doing on that uh
shout out to the five dollar super trap
from dirt I could show you what I'm
doing
on on the Pokemon theme man
when we playing uh miles you're gonna
have to you have to enlighten me when
we're playing
or are we not playing
are you gonna run on me miles
are you running on me
are you [ __ ] up on me miles
is that what you do with miles
huh
it's okay if you if you are man
that's what I'm playing right now
let me turn down the the audio all the
way because we don't really
need to hear it too much
Pokemon's good because it's like a
turn-based thing
I actually beat uh I beat Pokemon
uh I need to finish the review but I've
been so sick guys like I I could barely
move last week
it was bad I haven't felt like that in a
long time
so yeah so this is what I've been
playing man
got that final fantasy tactus move going
on
are you going to play
oh
hey babe can you get me a water
it's like really dry
added you want to play um
I don't even know what that is Paul
world
what is that
Mouse Team PlayStation versus attic team
Xbox uh we could end the console Wars
now
hold on I don't
give me a second
all right hold up
thank you babe
all right all right oh look it it auto
synced man it went straight to it so
let's see let's see miles let's see
Pokemon with guns let's stay away from
the Pokemon with guns
so let me show miles what he he working
with man
so this is currently when I'm rocking
with miles
this is my current setup man this is the
Pokemon that I'ma probably Rock in the
uh
and the thing with man
more like Pokemon but actually decent
I'll have to look that up someone's uh
put a link in the chat for like a
trailer or something
what fairy type
look out look at all these EVS I have I
have like a ridiculous amount of EVS
hmm
and look at that Gengar
miles
look at that Gengar
yeah I I got it going on right now man I
got it going on right now
oh I have one shiny I think uh I don't
know see I don't know the Pokemon like
that to know if they're shiny or not
uh but I I do have I'm pretty sure this
is a shiny
I'm pretty sure this is a shiny
I got this as a shine
it was in the last
uh Pokemon okay hold up we bout to live
react to this thing right now let me see
what this thing's called
you said it is called power world or
whatever
let's look up a YouTube video
a YouTube video guys
oh hold up you said you could see if
there's a shiny
you said the the lower left is the shiny
one
oh okay I see what you mean now
I wonder what a shiny Ditto is
TGs
there need I actually feel like
Pokemon would work really good as a
multiplayer multi-plat cross platform on
all platforms I think it would do very
well very well
all right so let's hope that um
I don't get copyright claimed for this
that would that would be unfortunate
let's look though let's look
uh where is it
let's switch the screen
from that to this power world thing
all right
let's look at this
you gotta probably need the the
desktop audio just a little bit
rocket pair pocket pair so originally
Pokemon was called um
pocketmon or something like that so it's
kind of interesting that the studio is
called that
so they got guns
I don't know part of me feels like this
isn't Pokemon if like you're shooting
guns instead of like battling Pokemon
like people don't realize there's a huge
competitive scene to Pokemon there's a
huge competitive scene like you know
right now I'm not really
able to go in there and and play people
I just got some of the people I would
like to use but there's a huge
competitive scene and I think people
they just see Pokemon as like some some
kids thing but they don't realize that
it gets real serious when it comes to
the actual Pokemon thing
it's okay
all right so let's let's start with
these gun thing
now I don't like these animations look
look at look at her like on the thing
I'm gonna be real with you guys I think
tim tams looks better so far oh so you
you
are you are you are you enslaving these
these Pokemon
okay maybe I could see a little bit more
okay okay I'm coming a little around
yeah
oh so you can combine Pokemon
yeah I feel you I feel you but they
don't like
I feel you okay maybe I could correct
myself for that
I feel you
[Music]
oh look at that man
I mean would you guys want the iron
lures to play this
would you guys want the iron lures to
play this
huh
guys be honest with me
I I assume it's a massive multiplayer
game
me and the girl after this probably
gonna watch smile
I watched like the first like 10-15
minutes of that movie last night it was
kind of creepy
so pretty much it's like an arc and
Pokemon
combo game
an arc and Pokemon like had a baby type
of game
I I could see why people would like
something like this it's like a survival
thing with Pokemon
they're really into these guns
what what is this
what is this guys
yo so they got the tears
they're the eating Pokemon yo this is
the dark Pokemon man this is what
they're not showing you with Pokemon
Pokemon getting ate killed
ah
it's not what they they ain't showing
you this man
okay you know when's this come out
better question miles is it in Game Pass
that's the better question
is it in Game Pass
is it have a release date
no it doesn't
We're not gonna watch another trailer
it's like what if Pokemon had more than
three months death time
not in Game Pass
that's unfortunate
so these are these uh attic shows gonna
go for the rest of the year because I
want to give Dart in them you know dirt
dirt's not even really part of the attic
show like he's not like a coach or
anything that may just be showing up and
doing me a solid every week and since
it's the holidays I was like dirt spend
time with your family man I got this i
got this
foreign
I like dirt though I like dirt
's a good dude
so you know what I like about this game
and I know this is really this is really
lazy of me
and I don't need no one telling me how
lazy I am in this game I like how I
could go to this quick assignment assign
all roles and then start the battle
and not do anything
at all
literally I just sit here
and let the game play itself
I like that
I mean I wish they would just let me
what's that word that you oh see why why
is she making me see we ain't doing that
we ain't doing that distance Striker
yeah there we go
look it is see look I ain't doing
nothing I'm just sitting here talking to
you guys about some games Enlighten Mike
let me get these the these levels up man
these levels up yes
someone out the door
who is it
we'll come in
yeah
do you not you're kicking me off oh I
I'll you after I get done with the show
you can have it back me and her are
going to watch him smile
what the [ __ ] is getting mad as hell
dude okay
triangle strategy
I like triangle strategy I can't say
it's better I I think I think triangle
strategy is one of the better turn based
games like this I've played in a long
time
I can honestly say that without a doubt
you know there is a fell fell cell
that's a good one
but triangle strategy is one of the
better
quality games I've played in a long time
that's like these but guess what flame
triangle strategy wouldn't let me do
this
why don't
pop the bearings
they wouldn't let me do this
Flame
I wonder why my camera would be bugging
today
I don't know
I don't know man
the two player caught made Tim ton fun
for me uh the co-op in Pokemon's kind of
trash a little bit
I mean it could be a lot better I'm
gonna be real with you guys it could be
a lot better
but yeah that's pretty much how the
attic show is going to be for the next
uh month you know just laid back
watching something you know might invite
some people in just just straight up
just talking
and plus me and King are starting our
other show so I'm trying to focus a
little bit of attention on that
uh so that way they both run effectively
and I don't have to worry about either
one of them
see look at this man I love it
oh you fine man you fine
see I've learned throughout the years
it's easier to do this solo thing
it could be easier you know but
I don't mind doing the solo stuff it's
just if I have a chat to talk to it's a
lot better
if I have a chat to talk to
and the good thing about a game like
this is I can just let it play while I
talk I don't even have to really engage
in the conversation too much
because the game's play in itself
you guys might have an issue with the
game playing itself but I don't care the
gang will play itself the gang will play
itself
you know I want Final Fantasy Tactics to
to come back in a big way I would really
enjoy that
tactics is the best game I've played
like this
just because of the story the original
tactics
now I'm not going to say the
story in the other games wasn't good but
tactics was good
you know I'm getting a lot of hate too
because of my opinions on God of War
a lot of people aren't feeling my
thought process on God of War
because I don't think it's like some
amazing game I think it's a good game
but I I do think Eldon ring is the
better game
and it seems like a lot of people aren't
about that they want me to
just completely bend the knee to God of
War completely and I won't do it
I think the the quality in God of War is
on another level
you know to be honest with you God of
War Ragnarok as much as I I don't like
to feed into Kings nonsense sometimes it
is it is like a DLC
you know it's not a bad thing it's just
more of the other one but I do think
it's drastically better in some ways
than 2018 but there's a lot of ways I
feel like 18 was better
that's just a give and take
I don't think it did anything new to
like be that best game ever made I've
seen people on Facebook say it's the
best game ever made
I mean I don't I don't understand how
how you feel that
you guys will be a little bit too much
with God of War man
guys be a little bit too much with God
of War
it's a good game great game even
but it's not all that
I could I could easily get game of the
year here's the thing it's such a good
game that I could if it got got a war
over Elder ring I wouldn't be upset
because I could see why people would see
that it's worthy of God of War
am I getting midnight Suns
I don't know
um you know right now I'm looking for a
job so I'm not really trying to spend
any extra money
I'm trying to get a little bit more
remote job because I feel like I've come
to the end of my area and how pathetic
my area is when it comes to finding a
job so I'm trying to do some more remote
stuff hopefully I'll find better
opportunities
if that makes sense to you guys
all right that's fine I don't care
yeah it's it's been a little ridiculous
how uh how
difficult it is to find a job right now
but
I got a couple I got two job interviews
next week
two man
guys what's your boy good luck man
in the post office we we have a post
office here
and sometimes they be they'd be hiring
see the problem is I live in such a a
low populated area
that there's not enough jobs to go
around so when there is a job all
opening somewhere there's like 200
people going for this stuff man it's
ridiculous I put a job application for
GameStop as a seasonal City at 250
people applied for that seasonal help
uh I've always been decent at the
interviews
I could say that
with all honesty I've been okay at
interviews like I'm not like fantastic
about them but I I know how I know what
kind of uh stuff they want to hear I
gotta I gotta update my resume that's
what I gotta do I gotta work with the
with Cognito because he's really good at
stuff like that you know he'll uh help
me
tailor a resume for what I need it for
so I've been trying to get my a plus too
my a plus certification but I've been
really struggling with the test I've
been following it by a couple points
took it I took it three times and I
failed it every time the last one I felt
about it one one point
see and a a huge problem too is it's
just the area I live in
you know it it's
it's frustrating
but
I've even been able to you know
live on on a pretty strict budget and
still get by
uh so it's it's it's it's good I I'm
doing things good plus you know uh IOP
has been a huge help too
wait
because now where I review games for you
guys and stuff I don't have to pay for
games and stuff so at least I could
still enjoy my hobby while I'm still
looking for another job so that's good
you know I'm thinking about playing
Callisto protocol is it either that or
midnight Suns what would you guys want
me to review more midnight Suns or
Callisto protocol
yeah
I'm curious on that what would you guys
prefer me to review more
Callisto
I don't know why my camera is is bugging
man
I'm not even worried about it right now
Callisto
I see midnight Sun's Midnight Sun
Callisto
might let Twitter decide that man I
might let Twitter decide that
um
Midnight Sun
midnight Sons get some good reviews what
did Callisto protocol get in reviews is
those reviews out yet
cholesterol protocol
what did Callisto get
one review broke embargo and it was a
five out of five oh
Callisto product I'll probably be the
last game I review for the year
because I I want
to spend the rest of time with my girl
and uh her daughter and my my family so
probably after cholesterol protocol
because IOP is taking two weeks off
uh we will not be having a podcast
we will not be having a podcast
the 25th or the first
uh so though we will not be having a
podcast those days so we are going to
take two weeks off uh most likely I'll
still probably do this little stream uh
I don't mind this
uh we have a huge play like we have a
lot planned for next year we have a lot
of coverage we're gonna do for you guys
next year
uh I'm still working on some new guests
I want to you know have some good
variety of guests next year who's some
what is some guests that you guys would
like
on IOP what are some guests that you
guys would like because uh you know we
we always like to give more perspectives
than just the people that we've had on
so that's why you know we're very big on
having new personalities on the show
now obviously it helps us like you know
find newer audience but I do think it's
nice that we can get so many variety of
voices on the show because you know
we're not one
certain person like we we are in every
podcast we don't really do anything like
that uh so it it's it's nice that since
we cover so many so all the consoles and
stuff we're able to really get anyone we
want that's one gonna come on
Nintendo influencers I've tried flame
I've tried I've generally reached out to
Nintendo influencers and they never get
back to me they always leave me on red
they leave Beyond red more than my girl
leaves me on red
huh so just go back to bed
my girls over there trying to sleep
that's why I went ahead and played a
game so so she can have most of the bed
because like my bed's this way
and she's like on the top part of it
uh but if I have like the full-blown
camera you won't be able to see like she
won't be able to stretch out
and I I didn't want to do that to her
so you know
we'll do this what bring Dawn on who's
Don
please don't say you're talking about
Don matrick
is that who you're talking about
is that who you want us to have on
Don matrick
that's interesting
donotaku
I don't okay so Cog is big on making
sure that like the people that come on
are influencers
uh you know but I like Donna taku
so let's see what we can do man let's
see what we could do
now I do have something special for you
guys
this coming up
son uh
the last podcast we do this this year
is going to be
the 18th
I I have a sp like I have this concept I
want to do like you guys remember when
we did the the rotating podcast where we
brought people in and out uh when it was
the Activision buying being bought by
Microsoft thing I want to do something
similar to that but like a celebration
of 2022 from content creation to games
to everything gaming related I I really
want to like just celebrate 2022 the
favorite favorite gays favorite content
moments favorite time of the year is to
be a podcaster and I want to rotate
people doing that but that takes a lot
of time and we're still in the early Pro
uh early plannings of it so I can't
guarantee you it's gonna happen but I'm
gonna do what I can
foreign
um we follow each other on Twitter
I don't know if zarya would ever be
interested in coming on because you know
he kind of does his own little thing
you know sometimes
you know and this is the community
itself uh sometimes I Zaire has always
been pretty real though I can honestly
say that about Zaire
um you know people could say what they
want about that dude he
he's always been about the entertainment
you know that's all he cares about he
doesn't really care about anything else
it's just entertaining he likes to make
people laugh like like and you can never
take that away from that man
and one thing you can say is his
community really supports him too they
really like it man they they
it's crazy the amount of super chats he
gets I used to
uh time stamp his stuff uh they used to
give me a little money to do all their
time stamps and man it's kind of crazy
the super chess that that man gets but
you know what I can really respect him
for like his regulars he pays them like
Zaire make sure his people are good and
I respect that because you know
IOP we don't take any of the money
you know uh we always make sure it's
reinvested back into the brand
but I don't see too many like hosts
split that money that they get from
Super chats and stuff and it's nice to
see Zaire do it he wants to make sure
his people are good and you got to
really got to give off to them on that
all right so
Phil all right
I can't speak too much on the fill
the feel Dominus the Phil Spencer
interview
um I will tell you that we are in the
works trying to make it happen
uh Cognito would kill me if I told you
anything related to what's going on with
that
um I don't know if it's gonna happen
because you know obviously all we could
do is ask but you know we are trying to
give you guys that interview spawn wave
spawn wave doesn't really mess with me
too much uh we have had him on the show
before for a Nintendo topic but it's
just that whole group just don't mess
with me man I've tried to get rgt I
think his name's that doesn't respond
player Essence kindness talks to me
every now and then when I respond uh
message him but like Miss click doesn't
respond either like that whole group
it's just it's just crazy man and I'm
not I
you could say what you want about
Dreamcast sky but during cat sky
is always willing to come on other
people's shows and you know maybe
they're busy maybe they're busy I don't
know I don't know these people
personally but it is it's
it's really frustrating when you feel
like you're being Hollywood to buy
someone
um
doctor disrespect I don't even know how
to get a hold of Dr disrespect
foreign
ogre tactics
unfortunately thought on the Xbox but
for some reason you know scoring has
decided to uh to skip this game on the
Xbox
I have it on Steam
uh do you do video actions on Steam
there was a three hour interview with
Todd Howard three hours is excessive fam
was there like a lot of good information
on the three hours
I saw a couple of the highlights on
Twitter
Mr Mighty plays he's definitely
potential to come on
uh dealer game definitely potential to
come on we're trying to get newer people
that's never been on the show because I
because like I said we're real big on
like different perspectives we've had
those individuals on before
foreign
they're time stamped
all right I'll look at them
we'll see we'll see
Plum Network I don't even know what that
is
is that like a YouTube channel who is
plum Network
who is plum Network guys
level 11 level eight
that just get me I definitely man we can
look into it
might try to get some of you on if we do
the 18th show
I have some of the people from the
community on see the problem is getting
Rand to people that we don't necessarily
know we've not seen in a podcast or any
form of that's why like cog's real big
on content creation like he feels like
it's really necessary to have a content
creator on because we can actually
monitor who they've been we can monitor
what kind of content they've made we can
validate and make sure that they're like
real to a degree there's a lot of people
and I'm not saying it's anyone in the
chat but there's a lot of people that
would intentionally
sabotage our podcast by like playing
like pornography or something uh on it
just so they can get one off on us so
you know it's very important that we
make sure and really you know double
check who we let on the show and stuff
ah
I like dirt dirt it's good man dirt's
good he he you know I hit him up and I
told him you know don't worry about
coming on the show today I do so I I
just chatted up with the folks you know
you take take your uh
take your couple weeks off man you you
deserved it
he's very okay you know what let me let
me look at this Plum Network
the problem is too is it's hard to get
some of these people to like respond to
me
shout out to two dollar super trap from
raid and blade uh Plum Network a
fantastic Channel very cool guy
so let's let's let's look at this Plum
Network
also all right
let me see if he's got a Twitter
and he does
and he's following me
all right so I think we can make that
work I think we can make that work guys
yeah let me actually put this dude
see I have something I under no
circumstances am I allowed to show you
guys but I have like a place that like
we put
potential guests that we would like to
have on or we have stuff in the works
uh so I'm gonna put him on the list and
I will reach out to him later he follows
me on Twitter too so that's good
now let me ask you guys a question
and don't flip out because I asked this
I know how you guys feel
um I'm gonna start bringing on more of
the PlayStation people on like J dub I
know you guys feel like they troll uh
see here's the thing when J Dub's on the
show with me he doesn't troll like that
though you know he's very fair he just
some of you just be getting triggered by
what he says I'm not saying it's anyone
in the chat but some of you sometimes
when these people are saying outlay
stuff on Twitter they just want a
reaction from you
and sometimes you guys be doing that man
yeah I always mess up for that you guys
know how it is
don't act surprised don't act like you
new to this
no I can't I can't really do king king
thrash man it's just King thrash
you know he he's made like negative
posts about me and stuff and you know
really trying I would say he's Cloud
chasing I mean maybe a form of cloud
chasing to a degree but sometimes I do
feel like he'd be doing a little too
much for no reason you know one time he
kind of like try to imply that I haven't
played like like Halo the campaign and
it's just like I've never you know one
thing you've never seen is someone come
out there and validate saying that I
haven't played a game
you know you know how I've reviewed 17
games this year
I've reviewed 17 games
and I've beat all of them I'm very big
on
making sure that I play a game to the
beginning to the end before I review
something I'm not one of those people
that review
something like that and I got to get
better on like if I don't like a game
to to make sure that I review it
regardless because I feel like because
my mindset's like I don't want to review
it unless I beat it but if I don't want
to beat it because I don't like it
that's that's the review I don't like
the game so I need to be better on that
too and I'm gonna do better on that next
year
hmm
uh we got mooch brap and boom
I feel you guys
you know I've never been invited on any
of booms podcasts
uh I don't mess with brap like that
we'll be real with you guys I I
personally
um I don't mess with rap like that I got
no issue with them but I don't mess with
them
yeah that's my issue with thrash he just
never lets people talk
uh you know and I feel like
you know it's just that that's that's
the beauty of this this YouTube thing we
do man for for engaging conversations
if that makes sense to you guys
I don't know who that is I'm gonna be
real with you I don't watch perhaps
podcasts I don't know uh you would have
to like
send me
send me like his Twitter information
it's like I said we I'm like if Carl hit
me up today and said I want to bring
brap on Sunday I'm not gonna like not
let him come on like I'm not that kind
of person you know if because just how I
personally feel about brap it like and
it's mainly content you know I don't
like the kind of content he makes and
you know we have difference of opinions
on content creation but I don't think
he's a bad dude
you know and I honestly think that you
know he's let this the internet
personality and that's just me
personally uh you know take over a
little bit but he's not a bad dude it's
just I prefer
you know
I don't know like
I don't mind people being negative on
stuff and I I do disagree with people
when they always say you know don't you
know be positive like
be positive when positive makes sense be
negative when negative makes sense I
don't agree with like
like leveling the scales one way or the
other if something is doing stuff that
they shouldn't be doing you got to be
negative about it if something is doing
something that they should be doing you
got to be positive about it and I
personally feel like a lot of these
people don't talk about the games
they're playing
you know they do a little segment at the
beginning they'll say oh I'm playing
this I'm playing that but you know when
they making these podcasts and videos
they they're not talking about that a
lot
and you know I will say iops a little
guilty of this sometimes you know uh I
remember when the preview builds came
out for God of War people asked us why
did we talk about the preview builds a
lot and you know we we could do better
on that too uh we could definitely do
better on that too we do talk about
games a lot but you know sometimes when
the weeks are just so heavy with
information uh you know sometimes we do
let the games like a new game just came
out fall between the cracks and we could
do better on that too
so that's why I like
working with with Carl King and solve
like they're very easily talked to like
for the most part we were running a
democracy and for the most part we never
have something where we all disagree on
something we might disagree on something
but it's never like a huge disagreement
all right let me see here let me go back
okay Meg I like amake if they can't make
a good dude
a little shop here
got a little bit of money
what sounds good for dinner you guys
like give me some some opinions on what
we can have for food
I need some opinions
sure some of you got some opinions
tk9 I have no clue that is chicken eye I
have no clue who tk9 is
and uh I will be posting
on um
um gave me addicts again I just I was so
sick guys there's no way
there's no way
it was not happening there was no way I
was gonna be able to post to to keep up
content on on my personal YouTube
channel because I didn't even feel like
breathing half the time man I slept for
like two days straight almost
and say I still feel a little
incongested but it's not it's not nearly
as bad as it was you know my girl really
helped take care of me when I was down
and out
t
does he have a Twitter chicken eye
I definitely want to give these
these uh smaller content creators
platforms
um
put his handle in there in the chat for
me
hey did you check the link I sent you
work wise uh yeah I looked at that
actually I looked at that for about 30
minutes yesterday
um I want to go ahead and redo my resume
before I start applying
so I I'm I'm jumping on that I really
appreciate everyone that put those links
in the chat because like I said my my
area is is is garbage but I was seeing a
lot of you know jobs that entry jobs
that I can get my hands on there's even
a couple that was saying that after I
worked the
like they're what's the probationary
hearing for the company that they'll
actually help me get my A-Plus uh so you
know I'm gonna let's see where it goes
man I'm gonna see where it goes
dark darkness I like him I got to get
him uh
gotta get him on the on the show too
I like dog
oh man that Berserker is just killing
stuff man
I like how you got they kind of cap you
on this game like you can't just over
level if you guys notice after this
match
they're not gonna let me level anything
up
uh they're they're gonna because you
have like
a like a party level in my party level
17 so I can't have anything above 17.
which makes sense
Callisto protocol man
I gotta do the Pokemon review
and then I will start the cholesterol
protocol
and obviously you guys know how I'll do
it I'll give you a I'll give you a a
stream on here first
and then after the stream uh you'll see
the the actual call to the YouTube
channel
I wasn't really feeling how I was seeing
it was a lot of um a lot of melee though
but you say people got like five out of
five and I'm pretty sure I know people
playing I haven't really talked to
anyone but I'm pretty sure if I reached
out to some of the reviewers I know they
would uh
I'm sure they're playing it
I feel like everyone's getting sick
ah
I don't know I'm I'm really looking
forward to that Mario movie too
looks very interesting
she went away
and I think I think I might start
streaming more on my YouTube channel
because I part of me doesn't want to
like
like separate the two I want to separate
and go to twitch but the other part of
me is like YouTube's got so good
at separating content that I'd be stupid
not to take advantage of it
because I man I know a lot of people say
but I I love this gaming [ __ ] dude I
love the gaming industry I love what it
represents some things I disagree with
but you know people can never say I
don't have the passion for it sacrifice
a lot of stuff to do this gaming stuff
um
you know back when it was just me like
the money thing didn't really matter to
me
uh but you know now
that I'm starting to take you know
especially like dating and stuff
seriously me and my girl have been
together for like a year like I gotta
look at stuff like that I gotta you know
make sure I get my money up so I could
take care of them better
so you know got decisions I got to make
you know you know I've never
as long as IOP is the thing I'm going to
be part of IOP
uh but you know as far as other content
I got to be choosy on what I make
because I got to dedicate more time to
you know doing better with just money in
general
no I'm not playing Warframe absolutely
not
it's not happening
thank you flame but you're not you're
not doing that to me
I will not play Warframe
see look
if you notice here like
none of these are going to level up
level cat because my level cap for the
party's only 17.
but you guys I think I'm gonna
in the Stream here man
uh
my girls daughter is getting a little
restless and I don't blame her you know
sitting on the bed she three man
I'm surprised she was sitting down for
as long as she was man
but I appreciate it for coming through
man
and I hope you guys have a good day
we'll see you on uh IOP this week
hopefully my camera will be working and
um
you guys have a good day